I hope you enjoyed that and I hope that
the intuition you have in the basketball
court you can take you to here and every
time you look at it nah gonna die
against the okay where are the bodies
right now that's not a rhetorical
question where are the points of
reference where in the bags for this
particular locus right where are we
measuring from a measuring to okay so
but this guy here my point of reference
is going to be we looked at this one
this before - I right so that's my one -
as I've said before these are all on the
axis right so I'm just gonna bucket in
his two cuts on the imaginary where's
our other point of reference
where's out on the back it's at negative
3 right so one two three on the real
axis there I am okay I hear my points of
reference so now I'm saying to be do it
find a place to stand
tell me the locus of points such that
when you measure your bearing to each of
these you get the same angle you get the
same argument okay then you traced out
this locus this was the first lock as we
did right if you draw a line all the way
through right part of this line forms
the locus or parts I should say which
pups it's the part of me I'm as well on
the outsides right so if you start from
here you can go off in this direction
you can stand anywhere there okay
for instance if I put a person with a
compass or
a complex gamma as a point there you can
imagine that person they're standing
with their compass looking at - I am
measuring one bearing and then looking
at maybe two three and naturally
measuring the same bag because they're
on the line of sight okay you see what's
going on but of course you don't have to
stand on that side you can also stay to
the opposite side
so how would we state the locus of this
set of points okay let's start with the
easy part they both lie on this aisle
don't lie that I put it first
okay what's the equation of the dolphin
what's dualistic
about it probably the easiest way based
on how I drew it based on how drew it is
to look for two features they mean like
a lot of toilets that before great how
wide ascends gradient okay I rise two
units and I run three units you happy
with that so it's a great right over by
two thirds which Chuck gels with the
fact that it's kind like a gentle
incline okay there's my gradient my
y-intercept is +2 okay down that's a
good start but I'm not finished mo right
because I don't want all of the line I
need to restrict the domain okay so I'm
going to say it's this slide for which
part
well less than Big E 3 or so greater
than zero don't mix up your real and
imaginary parts wait would you like
instead of using the X's would you be
able to make the domain using lies yes I
could I could stay in terms of rate so I
could say Y is less than 0 or Y is
greater than 2 in this case stating the
domain it stayed the range of our
equipment I think they're equivalent
but you'll notice they're only
equivalent because it's a linear
function right if I have like a parabola
or something else like that right then
you start to get Y blurring of like
which one is more important and
generally speaking we talk about domain
because we're thinking of exercies
inputs okay that is like a holdover from
the previous times where we were
thinking of X's and Y's as inputs
outputs but it's it's sort of a
tradition
worth holding on to okay because at
least it's a convention that's all going
to be consistent uh kind of yeah but
we're not you see here's a thing right
this is this function right I could just
as easily reframe it in terms of why
right so there's no reason why I have to
make it y equals I could make it x
equals just a little okay this
particular example the second the second
okay and by the way we didn't state we
didn't spank this sum equation over here
either we can state fairly easily though
what's its gradient minus one so
therefore the line itself is minus X but
be careful how you state itself domain
I'd probably say just like I have here
you do it in pieces okay don't say where
you can't go say where you can go that's
what so many years so I would say X
could be less is Europe or it can be
between zero and two 90s that's exactly
right right and do say all because
there's no number that has an x value
that is simultaneously less than zero
and between zero tubes but there's no
number like that okay
okay so that's what happens when you can
sit up the targets being the same let's
hijack this same diagram we use a
different color what if I asked you this
so Hattie on this diagram say it doesn't
include beyond like here I've included
right there
I've restricted the domain 0 to
annotating past two so I haven't stated
that it could go this week I already
have by excluding the boundary oh I
don't have an equality there you see if
I hadn't said that
then I'd be inquisitive and too but I
haven't said that so I'm not be creative
okay same as zero
all right now have a look at this guy
you're gonna need to pull out some of
your like comics of arithmetic when you
think about how Copic Stoppers operate
we need to quiet them what happens to
the I mistake here when you do buy
copies of this what I do with their
arguments you subtract right so I'm
gonna have this yep good question okay I
always say stop doing that because our
diagrams gonna get pretty busy pretty
soon but that's okay well we'll try and
run with it okay what does what does
this say that this is my locus what does
it mean okay actually maybe I'm wrong or
diagram for this cuz this is gonna make
my diner beautiful figure that z1 as one
of the points on this locus which means
it should satisfy this okay
so what this means is I'm saying that
argh of Zen one take away two I is the
z1 plus three okay now what is this
maybe this means this putt let Ted
Simons
measure the angle to z1 measured from -
I okay so let's have a look away that
anyways I'll keep this in green so I'm
gonna put another one in them in black I
guess in a minute okay so here's his 2i
right here I put my positive real axis
in
inverted commas it's parallel to the
positive real axis and then I measure my
angle and two clockwise opt isn't one so
this number in this angle I just
measured out that is the argument of Z 1
plus minus minus 2i you okay with that
that's where the argument news now what
I think about this guy where's this it's
the argument to the same complex number
over there but I'm measuring it from
negative three so I pop in my positive
real axis it's already there and then I
measure up until I'm facing it's a 1 so
this angle here is odd of z1 plus 3 okay
now to get the fact that you've got both
what are these lines called they start
somewhere and then they go forever
they don't go forever in both directions
so these are called rate intervals have
starts and ends Ray's have a start
meadow in and then lines though it's not
3rd and they just go for it ok so to
make sure I've got the other side of the
right let me put another complex number
on there let's call them let's comes
into ok so if I put Z 2 here and I'm
saying it's on the lockers and I've been
playing that are gives n to take away 2
I is also equal to R goes there 2 Plus 3
beware are these angles okay
okay for this one where am i measuring
from I'm measuring from to I right and
I'm measuring until I'm facing it zip -
yeah so is that cheese over here and 2
eyes up here keep in mind I prefer the
principal argument okay so I'm going to
go this way and I'm going to measure out
and like sir don't give me the principal
argument right because otherwise I think
the blue paw spike which will be outside
the domain of this value so this black
angle I've just mentioned it here is arc
or Z to take away - right you can tell
there are grooves into 2 plus trees
country right it's from negative 3 and
I'm measuring down this way until I'm
facing until my compass is looking at
Zed - and so this is either
two plus three and because the positive
real axis is axis I'll be drawing in
little parallel right you just got a
whole bunch of correspond game sorry
just repeat question okay so we're gonna
so we're gonna get to this case we're
gonna go to this case and I will draw a
new diagram because I've just completely
destroyed my diagram bit I didn't quite
finish writing it so what am I got here
right this is case two this is where
Alice do you know now that I've gone for
me TP up I've expanded out you can see
excuse me
the argument of this question is the
argument of one take away the younger in
yoga right now when you take away
numbers right just like when we were
doing this is it wonder to what you're
asking for is the difference you know
you tell me how far are these angles
from each other
relatively speaking so in other words
that's like saying okay take one measure
it and then subtract it from the other
but literally that's that's how you
calculate it right in like 110 eight
okay here I am 30 degrees is my
difference okay so what this is saying
is the difference between these two
arguments between these two bearings as
it were is PI radians 180 degrees you're
facing in opposite directions in order
to get the points that will satisfy this
line so quickly let's draw up a new line
over here we've got the same points to I
and maybe two three let's just meet is
just a bit yukking it up this time
the place I'm gonna be is still on the
same line right it's still the same line
but I've got to be here in the middle
right because now if I take some Zed
wonho's in to let some off the middle if
I put said one of this line right let's
think about where these arguments are so
if I put Z one here okay
I pop in my line it's point it's
parallel to the positive
like this like so and then I think about
my two measurements right
what is them is going to be this way
which Abel is that that's our of one
then one take away two I that's where
I'm measuring from - hey yeah actually
sorry that's the wrong spot
should be over there I was thinking you
accomplished that okay there's that
angle right so I measured down to look
at did what okay and then to get the
other one it's gonna be from here
measuring up right that's argument Z 1
plus 3 and you can see if I put this guy
and this guy together their difference
is gonna be PI because what is negative
this much and this one is positive by
the supplement okay do you see that and
obviously because they're parallel lines
and what kind of angles are they what
kind of goes there co interior angles
which are supplementary okay